- One way we rise on our
show is through connection,
so we thought we'd do a new segment
where we share our takes
on the most controversial
topics from past episodes,
to see if we come to a consensus on any.
This is...
♪ Finding common ground ♪
- Okay, run!
(audience applauds and cheers)
All right, Jessi, with the run.
- Yeah.
- Okay, so all we do
is hit this button and our super computer,
'cause it's totally
linked up to a computer,
will look back through
five seasons of shows
to find our most controversial subjects,
or topics, rather.
Then we're gonna try to
settle things on each topic.
We're gonna settle it
right here, are you ready?
- Okay, I'm ready to settle.
- All right, boom.
Well, don't be ready to settle,
that's not a way to live.
(Kelly and Common laugh)
Ooh!
Can, okay, okay.
This one came up from Jon Cryer,
when I was talking to him.
And can you be friends with an ex?
- Yes, I could definitely
be friends with a ex.
I mean-
- Like, how long was the relationship?
(audience laughs)
- I mean, I've been friends
with a lot of exes that I've had,
and they've been long relationships,
'cause most of 'em end pretty good.
I mean, we go through stuff at
the beginning of the breakup,
but then once we come to our grounds,
it's like, we both, we good
people, we cool people.
Are you friends with any of your exes?
- No.
(audience laughs and applauds)
I mean, here's the thing.
- No, ain't no judgment.
No judgment.
- I'm not not friends, but I feel like,
because I'm cool with-
I only have a couple that
I'm just like, hard pass.
(Common and audience laugh)
But no.
But, you know, a couple of them, though,
I don't have many exes, but like,
a couple of them are cool people.
Nothing wrong with them.
If we ran into each other,
we'd be totally friendly.
But that's the difference.
- What if they invited you?
If they invited you to a party with like,
like, they said, "Man, we having a party"
for some of their family members.
- Yeah, depending on the ex.
Yeah, no, I would be like, "Okay, cool.
Yeah, I'll show up."
Like, I just feel like
it can get awkward for-
It depends on who ended it
- Did that person-
Yeah.
- Or who it is.
And it depends, it's situational.
- Yeah. (laughs)
- Yeah, yeah.
- But for mostly, no.
No, no. (laughs)
I feel like that's awkward.
No common ground there.